This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是 TWO。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。对 1979 年来说，那对我是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 20 世纪 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.|||请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. All right. We talk a lot about emotions on this podcast. That is basically my bread and butter.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. All right. We talk a lot about emotions on this podcast. That is basically my bread and butter.|||大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们20多岁时的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎新老听众回到本播客，无论你身处世界何地。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析20多岁的心理学。好的。我们在本播客中经常谈论情绪。这基本上是我的看家本领。
We've spoken about anger and envy and heartbreak, happiness, everything in between. But one that we have missed all this time is resentment. And I was kind of thinking about why. And the reason I came to is probably because it's kind of an ugly emotion. At least that is what I think society would like to convince us. Resentment is that deep sense that we have been wronged, that we have been double-crossed, treated unfairly mistreated. And sometimes people confuse that with entitlement
We've spoken about anger and envy and heartbreak, happiness, everything in between. But one that we have missed all this time is resentment. And I was kind of thinking about why. And the reason I came to is probably because it's kind of an ugly emotion. At least that is what I think society would like to convince us. Resentment is that deep sense that we have been wronged, that we have been double-crossed, treated unfairly mistreated. And sometimes people confuse that with entitlement|||我们谈论过愤怒、嫉妒、心碎、快乐以及介于两者之间的种种情绪。但我们一直忽略的一种情绪是怨恨。我一直在思考这是为什么。我得出的原因可能是，这是一种有点丑陋的情绪。至少我认为社会是想这样说服我们的。怨恨是一种深层的感觉，觉得我们受到了委屈、遭到了背叛、受到了不公正或虐待。有时人们会把这与权利感混淆。
and feeling like we deserve more or better than what we have received. I tend to disagree. I think the root of resentment is respect and a sense of fairness. And when we feel resentful of somebody, it shows that we respect ourselves enough and we have enough sense of self-worth and self-esteem to know when somebody has crossed a line. We're not always the best at handling that resentment, though. Even if it does come from a justified place, it can sometimes blind us, blind us with disappointment, blind us with anger or bitterness, it can cause us to lash out or sometimes to end relationships we otherwise would have saved. I think it's the behavioral response to resentment that is what we see as ugly. But more than that, it's our shame. It's our shame around how our resentment causes us to act and to behave. So few of us have been really taught how to manage reactions like the ones caused by resentment. And what can emerge is a pattern of suppression and eventually explosion.
and feeling like we deserve more or better than what we have received. I tend to disagree. I think the root of resentment is respect and a sense of fairness. And when we feel resentful of somebody, it shows that we respect ourselves enough and we have enough sense of self-worth and self-esteem to know when somebody has crossed a line. We're not always the best at handling that resentment, though. Even if it does come from a justified place, it can sometimes blind us, blind us with disappointment, blind us with anger or bitterness, it can cause us to lash out or sometimes to end relationships we otherwise would have saved. I think it's the behavioral response to resentment that is what we see as ugly. But more than that, it's our shame. It's our shame around how our resentment causes us to act and to behave. So few of us have been really taught how to manage reactions like the ones caused by resentment. And what can emerge is a pattern of suppression and eventually explosion.|||并且觉得自己应得的应该比实际获得的更多或更好。我对此持不同意见。我认为怨恨的根源在于尊重和公平感。当我们对某人感到怨恨时，这表明我们足够尊重自己，并且拥有足够的自我价值感和自尊心，能够看出什么时候有人越界了。不过，我们在处理这种怨恨时并不总是那么在行。即使它确实出于正当的理由，有时它也会蒙蔽我们的双眼，用失望蒙蔽我们，用愤怒或苦涩蒙蔽我们，它会导致我们猛烈抨击，或者有时结束本可以挽救的关系。我认为，正是对怨恨的行为反应，才被我们视作丑陋的。但不仅如此，还有我们的羞耻感。对于怨恨如何驱使我们的行动和行为，我们感到羞耻。极少数人真正被教导过如何管理由怨恨引起的这类反应。而随之而来的往往是压抑、最终爆发的模式。
I've been considering this a lot in my own life recently, especially when it comes down to friendship. And it's something I know I really have to reach some kind of peace with. You know, to be vulnerable for a second, I think I've definitely been feeling a bit of resentment around feeling taking advantage of all like my efforts and some of my friendships have been taken for granted recently, and it's left me feeling kind of bitter and unacknowledged. Unacknowledged is probably the best word for it. And what I've come to realize is that when it comes to resentment, you have three options. And only one of them is actually helpful. You can let it
I've been considering this a lot in my own life recently, especially when it comes down to friendship. And it's something I know I really have to reach some kind of peace with. You know, to be vulnerable for a second, I think I've definitely been feeling a bit of resentment around feeling taking advantage of all like my efforts and some of my friendships have been taken for granted recently, and it's left me feeling kind of bitter and unacknowledged. Unacknowledged is probably the best word for it. And what I've come to realize is that when it comes to resentment, you have three options. And only one of them is actually helpful. You can let it|||我最近在自己的生活中经常思考这个问题，尤其是涉及友谊的时候。我知道我必须与它达成某种性和解。你知道，坦白地说，我觉得自己最近确实产生了一些怨恨，因为我感觉自己被占了便宜——比如我的努力和一些友情最近都被视为理所当然，这让我感到有些痛苦和不被认可。“不被认可”大概是最好的形容词了。我意识到，面对怨恨时，你有三种选择。而其中只有一种真正有帮助。你可以任由它。
control you, which often means fixating on past grievances or trying to justify your emotions, not letting bygones be bygones. You can let it consume your life and your relationships without ever giving anybody the opportunity to address it or to give you a differing version of reality. You could ignore it, which is basically the same as the above. It just delays the inevitable. It's going to produce the same outcome. Your resentment will take control and most likely result in some kind of loss. It's not to say that sometimes that's necessary.
control you, which often means fixating on past grievances or trying to justify your emotions, not letting bygones be bygones. You can let it consume your life and your relationships without ever giving anybody the opportunity to address it or to give you a differing version of reality. You could ignore it, which is basically the same as the above. It just delays the inevitable. It's going to produce the same outcome. Your resentment will take control and most likely result in some kind of loss. It's not to say that sometimes that's necessary.|||控制你，这通常意味着纠结于过去的委屈，或者试图为自己的情绪辩解，无法做到既往不咎。你可以让它吞噬你的生活和人际关系，却从不给任何人机会去解决它，或者向你提供对现实的不同看法。你可以选择忽视它，这基本上和上面差不多。它只是延缓了不可避免的结果。它会产生相同的结果。你的怨恨将会接管一切，并且很可能导致某种损失。这并不是说有时这是不必要的。
Sometimes people have wrong to you and your resentment is coming from a healthy place. But the final option, and I think that involves the example I just gave, is sitting with it, validating your response, and why it was only natural to kind of feel that way given the circumstances. You can really take away the shame of feeling what others might call entitled or what others might call ugly. And a step beyond that, you can address it with those around you. I think maturing is realizing that bringing up grievances or slights or problems is actually one of the biggest signs that you truly care about the other person, you care about the relationship, but also you care about yourself enough to endure the awkwardness and the
Sometimes people have wrong to you and your resentment is coming from a healthy place. But the final option, and I think that involves the example I just gave, is sitting with it, validating your response, and why it was only natural to kind of feel that way given the circumstances. You can really take away the shame of feeling what others might call entitled or what others might call ugly. And a step beyond that, you can address it with those around you. I think maturing is realizing that bringing up grievances or slights or problems is actually one of the biggest signs that you truly care about the other person, you care about the relationship, but also you care about yourself enough to endure the awkwardness and the|||有时人们确实对不起你，而你的怨恨源于一种健康的心态。但最后的选择，我认为这涵盖了我刚才举的例子，那就是正视它，认可你的反应，并理解在那种情况下产生那种感觉是多么自然。你真的可以摆脱那种被称为有特权感或被别人称为丑陋的感觉所带来的羞耻感。在此基础上，你可以与身边的人沟通解决这个问题。我认为走向成熟意味着意识到，提出委屈、怠慢或问题，实际上是你真正关心对方、关心这段关系的最大的迹象之一，同时也说明你足够关心自己，愿意去忍受那种尴尬和。
tension of trying to improve things. You know, it really does show a commitment to wanting to be there or at least a commitment to giving yourself some kind of answer. So I think resentment is such a maze, it's such a complicated emotion. Let's talk about how we can navigate it today. I want to speak on its psychological origins, its purpose, you know, even though it's a quote unquote ugly emotion. We know all emotions have a function, but also its consequences and its expression, how we can find a healthy resolution despite our of a knee-jerk reaction to lash out in response to resentment. Whatever it is that has called you to this episode, whether it is a lack of recognition at your job, an unequal friendship or relationship and unresolved conflict, a broken promise. I hope
tension of trying to improve things. You know, it really does show a commitment to wanting to be there or at least a commitment to giving yourself some kind of answer. So I think resentment is such a maze, it's such a complicated emotion. Let's talk about how we can navigate it today. I want to speak on its psychological origins, its purpose, you know, even though it's a quote unquote ugly emotion. We know all emotions have a function, but also its consequences and its expression, how we can find a healthy resolution despite our of a knee-jerk reaction to lash out in response to resentment. Whatever it is that has called you to this episode, whether it is a lack of recognition at your job, an unequal friendship or relationship and unresolved conflict, a broken promise. I hope|||试图改善现状时的紧张气氛。你知道，这确实表明了一种想要维系关系的承诺，或者至少是对给自己一个交代的支持。所以我觉得怨恨真是一个迷宫，是一种极其复杂的情绪。今天我们来谈谈如何应对它。我想谈谈它的心理根源、它的目的，你知道，尽管它是一种所谓的“丑陋”的情绪。我们知道所有情绪都有其功能，但也要谈谈它的后果和表达方式，以及如何在面对怨恨时，克服猛烈抨击的膝跳反射式反应，找到健康的解决方案。无论是什么原因吸引你收听这一期节目，是因为工作上缺乏认可、不平等的友谊或关系、未解决的冲突，还是破碎的承诺。我希望。
You can find some answers and if not, at least you find some clarity and some information. So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
You can find some answers and if not, at least you find some clarity and some information. So without further ado, let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.|||你能找到一些答案；如果没有，至少你能获得一些清晰的认识和信息。废话不多说，我们切入正题。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康健身专家等人进行交流，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.|||我们曾坚信植物油天生具有致炎性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。
That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.|||也就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上的《TWO percent》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so...
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so...|||每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论 20 世纪 80 年代的快克毒品。澄清一下，84 年对我很重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这儿，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的脉络了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以……
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important year. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host,
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah, for me, it's one of the most important year. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host,|||谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的，我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，
and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing|||也就是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.|||但我们仍在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌，生活变成了关于输赢的较量史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是的，那是两个不同层面的信任我希望你能够真正做一个好人加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the HardWay 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.|||随后进行的家庭法院听证会揭露了她言词中明显的自相矛盾之处。由此引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你在这份特定检测中篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.|||又有两名男子经历了同样的事情。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Resentment has a lot of different sources. The biggest one being a sense of unfairness, or, mistreatment as we spoke of before. Each of us has some kind of perception about how we should be treated and what we deserve from those around us. It's something that we develop pretty early on by watching how others are treated, experiencing how our parents treat us, what they tell us is right or wrong, how we feel when we are treated poorly and of course our self-esteem and our
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Resentment has a lot of different sources. The biggest one being a sense of unfairness, or, mistreatment as we spoke of before. Each of us has some kind of perception about how we should be treated and what we deserve from those around us. It's something that we develop pretty early on by watching how others are treated, experiencing how our parents treat us, what they tell us is right or wrong, how we feel when we are treated poorly and of course our self-esteem and our|||在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。怨恨有许多不同的来源。其中最大的一個来源是不公平感，或者正如我们之前所说的那样，受到了虐待。我们每个人对我们应该受到怎样的对待以及我们应该从周围人那里得到什么都有某种看法。这是我们在很小的时候通过观察别人如何被对待、体验父母如何对待我们、他们告诉我们什么是对是错、当我们受到不公正对待时的感受，当然还有我们的自尊和我们的自尊心。
sense of self-worth. Things that we commonly believe we deserve a pretty basic. I would say these aren't controversial. Every single person alive today deserves respect and recognition, deserves kindness, reciprocity. You know, we want to feel like our emotional, physical, social, mental, all those contributions are matched and we want to feel valued and loved and cared for. These are often our basics, the bare minimum of what is expected from others as a human, human being. And if you have a healthy sense of self-esteem and sense of self-worth, you don't feel like it's too much to ask for for people to meet these emotional needs or these basics of respect, knowing that you would treat them the same way. These are, as I said, the fundamentals, the most
sense of self-worth. Things that we commonly believe we deserve a pretty basic. I would say these aren't controversial. Every single person alive today deserves respect and recognition, deserves kindness, reciprocity. You know, we want to feel like our emotional, physical, social, mental, all those contributions are matched and we want to feel valued and loved and cared for. These are often our basics, the bare minimum of what is expected from others as a human, human being. And if you have a healthy sense of self-esteem and sense of self-worth, you don't feel like it's too much to ask for for people to meet these emotional needs or these basics of respect, knowing that you would treat them the same way. These are, as I said, the fundamentals, the most|||自我价值感而逐渐形成的。我们普遍认为我们应得的东西其实相当基础。我认为这些并不具有争议。当今活着的每一个人都值得尊重和认可，值得善意和回报。你知道，我们希望感到我们的情感、身体、社交、精神以及所有这些付出都是对等的，我们希望感到自己被珍视、被爱护和被关怀。这些通常是我们的基础，作为一个活生生的人，对他人抱有的最低期望。如果你拥有健康的自尊心和自我价值感，你不会觉得要求人们满足这些情感需求或基本的尊重是过分的要求，因为你知道你会以同样的方式对待他们。正如我所说，这些是根本，是最
basic things. Obviously, the more we trust someone, the more we may come to expect from them. Yes, you know, your boyfriend or your best friend and a stranger on the street should both show you respect and kindness, but we might expect our best friend to show us things like generosity, more reciprocity, more kindness than we would expect from a stranger. Studies have shown that resentment is most powerful when it is felt towards someone close to us. We are less likely to experience as intense amount of resentment towards that stranger than towards someone that we love because our expectations of them, and our trust in them is more significant, is higher.
basic things. Obviously, the more we trust someone, the more we may come to expect from them. Yes, you know, your boyfriend or your best friend and a stranger on the street should both show you respect and kindness, but we might expect our best friend to show us things like generosity, more reciprocity, more kindness than we would expect from a stranger. Studies have shown that resentment is most powerful when it is felt towards someone close to us. We are less likely to experience as intense amount of resentment towards that stranger than towards someone that we love because our expectations of them, and our trust in them is more significant, is higher.|||基本的事情。显然，我们对某人越信任，我们对他们的期望也可能越高。是的，你知道，你的男朋友、你的闺蜜和街上的陌生人都应该对你表现出尊重和善意，但我们可能会期望我们的闺蜜向我们展现慷慨、更多的回报、更多的善意，这是我们不会对陌生人抱有的期望。研究表明，当我们对身边亲近的人产生怨恨时，这种怨恨最为强烈。与我们所爱的人相比，我们不太可能对那个陌生人产生如此强烈的怨恨，因为我们对他们的期望以及对他们的信任更为重大、更高。
Essentially, resentment emerges when our expectations about how we should be treated based on the individual, based on the context and our actions, our expectations are not met. And this can be triggered by a number of experiences, like being taken advantage of. Maybe you're always paying for everything. You are always giving people gifts, navigating thank you, always putting down gas money and never getting that reciprocated. Another example is being put down or comments or criticisms that you think are unfair.
Essentially, resentment emerges when our expectations about how we should be treated based on the individual, based on the context and our actions, our expectations are not met. And this can be triggered by a number of experiences, like being taken advantage of. Maybe you're always paying for everything. You are always giving people gifts, navigating thank you, always putting down gas money and never getting that reciprocated. Another example is being put down or comments or criticisms that you think are unfair.|||本质上，当我们在特定个人、特定情境以及我们的行为基础之上，对于我们应该受到怎样的对待的期望没有得到满足时，怨恨便会产生。这可能会由多种经历触发，比如被占便宜。也许你总是包揽所有开销。你总是送别人礼物，费尽心思求一句谢谢，总是主动支付油钱却从未得到回报。另一个例子是遭到贬低，或者听到你认为不公平的评论或批评。
You feel like someone is not seeing the situation the way you are or giving you credit. You maybe resent them for an assumption that they've made about you without full information or the fact that they feel like you don't have enough self-respect and that you would, you know, allow them to speak to you that way. being dismissed, I think, also fits into this category, feeling overlooked or unheard like at work when you put in the long hours and they don't turn into a promotion or a pay rise. Having your feelings or you're interested, neglected by someone you thought would care is another pretty serious example.
You feel like someone is not seeing the situation the way you are or giving you credit. You maybe resent them for an assumption that they've made about you without full information or the fact that they feel like you don't have enough self-respect and that you would, you know, allow them to speak to you that way. being dismissed, I think, also fits into this category, feeling overlooked or unheard like at work when you put in the long hours and they don't turn into a promotion or a pay rise. Having your feelings or you're interested, neglected by someone you thought would care is another pretty serious example.|||你觉得某人没有以你的方式看待情况，或者没有给予你应有的认可。你可能会因为他们在没有掌握全部信息的情况下对你做出的某种假设而怨恨他们，或者因为他们觉得你缺乏自尊，竟然会允许他们那样对你说话而感到怨恨。我认为，遭到无视也属于这一范畴，感觉自己被忽略或心声无人倾听，比如在工作中你付出了漫长的工作时间，却未能换来晋升或加薪。你以为会在意你的人却忽视了你的感受或你的利益，这是另一个相当严重的例子。
An example of this that really comes to mind for me is cheating. How can you not feel resentment around something like that? being so vulnerable and open and trusting someone, letting them see you, and kind of finding out that perhaps they just don't care. I think this comes back to perhaps the biggest source of personal and relational resentment. Having these kinds of relationships with people who insist that their needs are more important than your own. It's interesting because a friend of mine was telling me the other day about how unfortunately her parents are getting divorced after being married for nearly 30 odd years. And she was really fine with me sharing the story, but she was explaining to me
An example of this that really comes to mind for me is cheating. How can you not feel resentment around something like that? being so vulnerable and open and trusting someone, letting them see you, and kind of finding out that perhaps they just don't care. I think this comes back to perhaps the biggest source of personal and relational resentment. Having these kinds of relationships with people who insist that their needs are more important than your own. It's interesting because a friend of mine was telling me the other day about how unfortunately her parents are getting divorced after being married for nearly 30 odd years. And she was really fine with me sharing the story, but she was explaining to me|||真正浮现在我脑海中的一个例子就是出轨。面对那样的事情，你怎么能不感到怨恨呢？表现得如此脆弱、敞开心扉并信任某人，让他们看清真实的你，结果却发现对方可能根本不在乎。我认为这归根结底或许是个人及人际怨恨的最大来源。与那些坚信自己的需求比你更重要的人维持这种关系。有趣的是，我的一位朋友前几天告诉我，她的父母在结婚近三十多年后不幸离婚了。她其实并不介意我分享这个故事，但她向我解释说，
that her mom had basically never recovered from being the one who gave up her career. And it was meant to be temporary, but, you know, then her siblings were born. And eventually her dad basically had convinced her to stay at home permanently. And here she was, years later, feeling like she hadn't fulfilled her potential, harboring a decades-long resentment around her needs not being as important that she'd never really processed. You know, her needs were being put second. She had these desires and these intentions for her life. And she kind of resented, I guess, my friend's dad, for never taking them seriously. And I'm sure it's more complex than that, but I think it's a really good example. And there are so many stories exactly like that one.
that her mom had basically never recovered from being the one who gave up her career. And it was meant to be temporary, but, you0 know, then her siblings were born. And eventually her dad basically had convinced her to stay at home permanently. And here she was, years later, feeling like she hadn't fulfilled her potential, harboring a decades-long resentment around her needs not being as important that she'd never really processed. You know, her needs were being put second. She had these desires and these intentions for her life. And she kind of resented, I guess, my friend's dad, for never taking them seriously. And I'm sure it's more complex than that, but I think it's a really good example. And there are so many stories exactly like that one.|||她的妈妈基本上一直未能从当年放弃事业的那种状态中恢复过来。这本来只是暂时的，但你知道，后来她的兄弟姐妹出生了。最终她爸爸基本上说服了她永远留在家中。多年后，她觉得自己没有发挥出潜力，内心里怀着一种长达数十年的怨恨——因为她的需求被认为不那么重要，而这种怨恨她从未真正化解过。你知道，她的需求被置于次要地位。她对自己的生活有着这些渴望和意愿。我想她大概是在怨恨我朋友的爸爸，从未认真对待过这些。我确信情况比这更复杂，但我认为这是一个非常好的例子。而且，像这样的故事实在是太多了。
The thing is that sometimes it's hard to express why you feel the way that you feel. What is it about their behavior that is insinuating that somewhere deep down they don't respect you or you feel like they don't see you or they don't care about you? Here is the thing though. You could search for that reason or you could search for that example that has made you feel resentful your whole life for months, for weeks. And I don't actually think that you need a justification for your resentment to still feel that way. You know, obviously, you probably eventually need to know why you're feeling mistreated to be able to express that to the other person.
The thing is that sometimes it's hard to express why you feel the way that you feel. What is it about their behavior that is insinuating that somewhere deep down they don't respect you or you feel like they don't see you or they don't care about you? Here is the thing though. You could search for that reason or you could search for that example that has made you feel resentful your whole life for months, for weeks. And I don't actually think that you need a justification for your resentment to still feel that way. You know, obviously, you probably eventually need to know why you're feeling mistreated to be able to express that to the other person.|||问题在于，有时很难表达你为什么会有这种感觉。他们的什么行为在暗示，他们在心底深处并不尊重你，或者让你觉得他们看不到你、不在乎你？不过，关键在于。你可以寻找那个让你感到怨恨的原因，或者寻找那个让你几个月、几周以来一直感到怨恨的例子。其实我并不认为你需要为你的怨恨找到一个正当理由，才能去感受这种情绪。你知道，显然，你最终可能需要知道为什么自己会觉得受到虐待，才能向对方表达这一点。
But the explanation doesn't always come before the feeling. Normally we feel resentful before we realize where it has come from. Maybe I should explain this a little bit better. Basically, the emotion needs to come first before we can rationalize them. If we think we need some reason to feel a certain way, to feel an emotion, we will always suppress or diminish our feelings because our reaction always precedes our explanation. If we ignore it, that is when we see so many of the negative consequences that we were discussing before.
But the explanation doesn't always come before the feeling. Normally we feel resentful before we realize where it has come from. Maybe I should explain this a little bit better. Basically, the emotion needs to come first before we can rationalize them. If we think we need some reason to feel a certain way, to feel an emotion, we will always suppress or diminish our feelings because our reaction always precedes our explanation. If we ignore it, that is when we see so many of the negative consequences that we were discussing before.|||但解释并不总是在感觉之前出现。通常情况下，我们在意识到怨恨从何而来之前，就已经感到怨恨了。也许我应该把这一点解释得更好一点。基本上，在我们将情绪理性化之前，情绪本身需要先出现。如果我们认为自己需要某种理由才能有某种感受、才能体验到某种情绪，我们就会永远压抑或贬低自己的感受，因为我们的反应总是先于我们的解释。如果我们忽视它，这正是我们看到之前讨论过的那么多负面后果的时候。
So the signs that what you're feeling is actually a symptom of resentment include anger, that is the biggest reaction to injustice that we probably come up. across. And you know, emotions are not solely confined to our minds. They also take residence in our body. So we might feel physically tense, physically enraged, our heart rate might go up in response to an event or a situation that has made us feel resentment. Hostility is another big one. One theory I read on this was that hostility is actually more of a protective mechanism to keep someone at a distance who has hurt us by coming off cold or kind of numbing ourselves to their presence or our own emotional reaction by shutting down.
So the signs that what you're feeling is actually a symptom of resentment include anger, that is the biggest reaction to injustice that we probably come up. across. And you know, emotions are not solely confined to our minds. They also take residence in our body. So we might feel physically tense, physically enraged, our heart rate might go up in response to an event or a situation that has made us feel resentment. Hostility is another big one. One theory I read on this was that hostility is actually more of a protective mechanism to keep someone at a distance who has hurt us by coming off cold or kind of numbing ourselves to their presence or our own emotional reaction by shutting down.|||因此，表明你的感受实际上是怨恨症状的迹象包括愤怒，这可能是我们遇到的对不公最大的反应。而且你知道，情绪并不仅仅局限于我们的头脑中。它们也会在我们的身体里驻留。因此，面对让我们感到怨恨的事件或情况时，我们可能会感到身体紧绷、怒火中烧，心率可能会上升。敌意是另一个重要表现。我读过关于这方面的一个理论，认为敌意实际上更多是一种保护机制，通过表现得冷漠，或者通过关闭心门、让自己对对方的存在或自己的情绪反应感到麻木，来与伤害过我们的人保持距离。
Basically, this person has hurt us. We don't want to let them in again. So we initiate a sense of hostility to keep them at bay. Lashing out is kind of like this as well. The reason we often do this is a very primal urge to kind of fight back. You know, if someone is hurting us in a way, lashing out shows them that we can cause them the same level of pain. So essentially it's being like, don't mess with me.
Basically, this person has hurt us. We don't want to let them in again. So we initiate a sense of hostility to keep them at bay. Lashing out is kind of like this as well. The reason we often do this is a very primal urge to kind of fight back. You know, if someone is hurting us in a way, lashing out shows them that we can cause them the same level of pain. So essentially it's being like, don't mess with me.|||基本上，这个人伤害了我们。我们不想再让他们走进我们的生活。所以我们产生了敌意，好让他们知难而退。猛烈抨击也有点类似。我们经常这样做，是因为有一种非常原始的想要反击的冲动。你知道，如果有人以某种方式伤害了我们，猛烈抨击会让他们知道，我们也能让他们承受同样程度的痛苦。所以这本质上就像是在说：别惹我。
we respond to the threat, as we would call it. It's very evolutionary, a very instinctual explanation, but one we should definitely consider. Just a quick reminder here. All of those feelings of resentment are valid. If you feel like you have been crossed, you're feeling a sense of injustice. That is something that you should definitely interrogate,
we respond to the threat, as we would call it. It's very evolutionary, a very instinctual explanation, but one we should definitely consider. Just a quick reminder here. All of those feelings of resentment are valid. If you feel like you have been crossed, you're feeling a sense of injustice. That is something that you should definitely interrogate,|||我们对所谓的威胁做出反应。这是一个非常符合进化论、非常本能的解释，但绝对是我们应该考虑的。这里有个小提醒。所有这些怨恨的情绪都是合理的。如果你觉得自己受到了侵犯，感到了不公。这绝对是你应该审视的事情，
but that doesn't mean that your behavior is valid. Hostility, lashing out, they might feel comforting, but it's also unkind. So try and really think about why you have this impulse before you let it rule you, before you let it control you. You don't want to suddenly be in a race to the bottom, you know, each of you responding to the other with even more negativity until the relationship is destroyed. You can be upset and I think still be looking for a solution or be civil or be able to
but that doesn't mean that your behavior is valid. Hostility, lashing out, they might feel comforting, but it's also unkind. So try and really think about why you have this impulse before you let it rule you, before you let it control you. You don't want to suddenly be in a race to the bottom, you know, each of you responding to the other with even more negativity until the relationship is destroyed. You can be upset and I think still be looking for a solution or be civil or be able to|||但这并不意味着你的行为是合理的。敌意、猛烈抨击，它们或许会让你感到一丝安慰，但这也是不友善的。因此，在让这种冲动主宰你、控制你之前，试着认真思考一下为什么你会有这种冲动。你肯定不想突然陷入一场恶性循环，你知道，彼此都用更多的负面情绪来回应对方，直到这段关系彻底破裂。你可以感到难过，但我认为你仍然可以去寻找解决方案，或者保持文明，或者能够。
respect yourself enough to not do something that you think will damage you further in the future or damage that relationship further. So another symptom is withdrawal, feeling like if you just kind of fade out of their life, we don't really have to endure what is happening. We never really have to look for closure, not the most mature solution, but again, we aren't necessarily acting from a place of maturity when we feel resentment. We are acting from a place of protection, impulse, what is going to make us feel better? What is going to make us feel safest? Sometimes it's emotional avoidance. Sometimes we also just don't have a choice. If the damage is done, if this person has hurt us, sometimes the only way to get over that is to be like,
respect yourself enough to not do something that you think will damage you further in the future or damage that relationship further. So another symptom is withdrawal, feeling like if you just kind of fade out of their life, we don't really have to endure what is happening. We never really have to look for closure, not the most mature solution, but again, we aren't necessarily acting from a place of maturity when we feel resentment. We are acting from a place of protection, impulse, what is going to make us feel better? What is going to make us feel safest? Sometimes it's emotional avoidance. Sometimes we also just don't have a choice. If the damage is done, if this person has hurt us, sometimes the only way to get over that is to be like,|||自尊自爱，不做那些你认为未来会进一步伤害你或进一步破坏这段关系的事情。因此，另一个症状是退缩，觉得如果你只是淡出他们的生活，我们就真的不必忍受正在发生的事情了。我们永远不必真正去寻找一个了结，这虽然不是最成熟的解决方案，但话说回来，当我们感到怨恨时，我们的行为未必出于成熟。我们的行为源于保护、冲动，什么能让我们感觉更好？什么能让我们感觉最安全？有时这是情感回避。有时我们也别无选择。如果伤害已经造成，如果这个人已经伤害了我们，有时克服这一点的唯一方法就是：
no, I'm sorry. I am fully done. I am fully ready to separate myself from this situation and there is nothing you can say. Like I said before, it's when these reactions are suppressed that our resentment becomes most powerful. It's like putting a lid on a boiling pot. The pot is still boiling. Eventually you're not going to be able to hold it anymore. You cannot suppress your resentment. And the solution to this is having a way to articulate what you're feeling.
no, I'm sorry. I am fully done. I am fully ready to separate myself from this situation and there is nothing you can say. Like I said before, it's when these reactions are suppressed that our resentment becomes most powerful. It's like putting a lid on a boiling pot. The pot is still boiling. Eventually you're not going to be able to hold it anymore. You cannot suppress your resentment. And the solution to this is having a way to articulate what you're feeling.|||不，对不起。我彻底受够了。我完全准备好将自己从这种境况中剥离出来，你无话可说。正如我之前所说，正是当这些反应被压抑时，我们的怨恨才会变得最为强大。这就好比给一锅沸水盖上盖子。水还在沸腾。最终你将再也压制不住。你无法压抑你的怨恨。而解决这个问题的办法是找到一种方法来清晰表达你的感受。
Because if there is one thing this episode leaves you with is that resentment is not a nasty or a bad emotion when it's given its due respect. When we let it expand into entitlement and revenge and vengefulness, then it becomes unhealthy. But when we, you know, really get the chance to examine it, when we are able to label it and name it, it actually serves a lot of healthy functions. I think it's better to kind of think of your resentment.
Because if there is one thing this episode leaves you with is that resentment is not a nasty or a bad emotion when it's given its due respect. When we let it expand into entitlement and revenge and vengefulness, then it becomes unhealthy. But when we, you know, really get the chance to examine it, when we are able to label it and name it, it actually serves a lot of healthy functions. I think it's better to kind of think of your resentment.|||因为如果本期节目能给你留下什么启示的话，那就是：怨恨在获得应有的尊重时，并不是一种恶毒或糟糕的情绪。当我们任由它膨胀为特权感、复仇心和报复欲时，它才变得不健康。但当我们真正有机会去审视它、能够为它贴上标签并命名它时，它实际上起到了许多健康的作用。我认为最好把你的怨恨看作。
If we're going to reframe this, think of your resentment as an emotional alarm. It is an emotional symptom that something is wrong with your relationship, with your circumstances, with your expectations. it's a red flag that needs your attention. But when that is ignored, that is when it begins to consume your mental and emotional energy. For example, you know, if you're resenting your parents for, I don't know, not coming to see you over the holidays or spending more time with your siblings, whatever it is, that is a sign
If we're going to reframe this, think of your resentment as an emotional alarm. It is an emotional symptom that something is wrong with your relationship, with your circumstances, with your expectations. it's a red flag that needs your attention. But when that is ignored, that is when it begins to consume your mental and emotional energy. For example, you know, if you're resenting your parents for, I don't know, not coming to see you over the holidays or spending more time with your siblings, whatever it is, that is a sign|||如果我们换个角度来看，把你的怨恨当作一个情感警报器。它是某种情感症状，表明你的关系、你的境况、你的期望出了问题。这是一个需要你关注的红灯。但当它被忽视时，它就开始消耗你的精神和情感能量。例如，你知道，如果你因为父母没有在节假日来看你，或者花更多时间陪你的兄弟姐妹而对他们感到怨恨，无论原因是什么，这都是一个迹象。
that you feel the relationship is unbalanced. That is the red flag. That is the alarm. So address that. Hear their perspective, if you would like. I think when we open up. about our resentment, we naturally remove some of its, some would say selfish components, because resentment does tend to blind us to other people's perspectives because it's very
that you feel the relationship is unbalanced. That is the red flag. That is the alarm. So address that. Hear their perspective, if you would like. I think when we open up. about our resentment, we naturally remove some of its, some would say selfish components, because resentment does tend to blind us to other people's perspectives because it's very|||表明你觉得这段关系失衡了。这就是红灯。这就是警报。所以要去解决它。如果你愿意，听听他们的看法。我认为，当我们敞开心扉谈论我们的怨恨时，我们自然会剥离它的一些会被人认为是自私的成分，因为怨恨确实往往会让我们对别人的视角视而不见，因为它非常。
centered on our own experiences. It's centered on our experiences, our expectations, our emotions. And sometimes that can make us blind to why somebody acted the way they did, not out of cruelty, not out of a malicious place, but just from an unaware place. you know, you might resent your friend for being late because you feel like she doesn't value your time. And that is going to remain your interpretation. You are at the center. You are the one who was aggrieved unless you speak to her about it. And you realize, you know, actually she's dealing with a lot of work stress. She's overcommitting. It's not that she doesn't value your time. It's that she doesn't value or organize her time. And I've tended to find that resentment fades with more information. Another explanation about why resentment can be beneficial is that it kind of reveals to us what we value. We wouldn't have this visceral, intense kind of emotional reaction if we were apathetic towards our circumstances or to what's going on or to the person that our resentment is directed towards. Like I said, if it's a stranger who's not showing you respect or generosity or reciprocity, you kind of don't care.
centered on our own experiences. It's centered on our experiences, our expectations, our emotions. And sometimes that can make us blind to why somebody acted the way they did, not out of cruelty, not out of a malicious place, but just from an unaware place. you know, you might resent your friend for being late because you feel like she doesn't value your time. And that is going to remain your interpretation. You are at the center. You are the one who was aggrieved unless you speak to her about it. And you realize, you know, actually she's dealing with a lot of work stress. She's overcommitting. It's not that she doesn't value your time. It's that she doesn't value or organize her time. And I've tended to find that resentment fades with more information. Another explanation about why resentment can be beneficial is that it kind of reveals to us what we value. We wouldn't have this visceral, intense kind of emotional reaction if we were apathetic towards our circumstances or to what's going on or to the person that our resentment is directed towards. Like I said, if it's a stranger who's not showing you respect or generosity or reciprocity, you kind of don't care.|||以我们自身的体验为中心。它以我们的体验、我们的期望、我们的情绪为中心。有时这会让我们看不到某人为什么会做出那种行为，那不是出于残忍，也不是出于恶意，而只是出于一种浑然不觉的状态。你知道，你可能会因为朋友迟到而怨恨她，因为你觉得她不重视你的时间。这会一直是你的解读。你是中心。除非你跟她谈谈，否则你就是那个受了委屈的人。然后你意识到，其实她正在应对很大的工作压力。她承接了太多事情。并不是她不重视你的时间，而是她不重视或没有安排好她自己的时间。我往往发现，随着获得更多信息，怨恨会逐渐消退。关于怨恨为什么会有益的另一个解释是，它在某种程度上向我们揭示了我们珍视什么。如果我们对自己的处境、对正在发生的事情或者对我们怨恨的对象无动于衷，我们就不会产生这种本能的、强烈的情绪反应。就像我说的，如果是一个没有向你表现出尊重、慷慨或回报的陌生人，你其实并不在乎。
The reason we feel resentment so strongly, especially when it comes to like our partners or our family, is because we have a sense of expecting more from them. If we value friendship, you know, we are going to resent our friends for not making an effort or for canceling plans last minute because we value the friendship. If you value success and praise, you're going to resent not getting that or not getting the acknowledgement that you deserve for your hard work. or your accomplishments. If you value loyalty, you resent feeling like you've been put second behind somebody else.
The reason we feel resentment so strongly, especially when it comes to like our partners or our family, is because we have a sense of expecting more from them. If we value friendship, you know, we are going to resent our friends for not making an effort or for canceling plans last minute because we value the friendship. If you value success and praise, you're going to resent not getting that or not getting the acknowledgement that you deserve for your hard work. or your accomplishments. If you value loyalty, you resent feeling like you've been put second behind somebody else.|||我们之所以会有如此强烈的怨恨感，尤其是在面对伴侣或家人时，是因为我们对他们抱有更高的期望。如果我们珍视友谊，你知道的，我们就会因为朋友不肯付出努力或者最后一分钟取消计划而感到怨恨，因为我们珍视这段友情。如果你珍视成功和赞赏，你就会因为没有得到这些，或者没有因为你的努力或成就得到应有的认可而感到怨恨。如果你珍视忠诚，你就会因为觉得自己被排在别人后面而感到怨恨。
If you value freedom, I don't know, you will resent being caged or feeling like you have lost your independence. So resentment serves as a clue for, A, what needs to change in our lives to bring us peace, and B, what we value. And finally, you know, some psychologist would suggest. that it's a form of protest. I know I mentioned this before. I'm kind of repeating myself,
If you value freedom, I don't know, you will resent being caged or feeling like you have lost your independence. So resentment serves as a clue for, A, what needs to change in our lives to bring us peace, and B, what we value. And finally, you know, some psychologist would suggest. that it's a form of protest. I know I mentioned this before. I'm kind of repeating myself,|||如果你珍视自由，我不知道，你就会怨恨被囚禁，或者觉得失去了独立性。因此，怨恨充当了一个线索：A，我们的生活需要做出什么改变才能带来平静，B，我们珍视什么。最后，你知道，一些心理学家会认为，这是一种抗议的形式。我知道我之前提到过这一点。我有点在重复自己，
but it's basically a way for our body and our mind to almost respond to an injustice by closing off emotionally, by depriving somebody access to us, by creating an emotional state that will influence our behavior to avoid being hurt again, to avoid having our ego kind of cross,
but it's basically a way for our body and our mind to almost respond to an injustice by closing off emotionally, by depriving somebody access to us, by creating an emotional state that will influence our behavior to avoid being hurt again, to avoid having our ego kind of cross,|||但这基本上是我们的身体和心灵对不公正的一种回应方式——通过情感上的自我封闭，剥夺某人接近我们的权利，创造一种能够影响我们行为的情感状态，以避免再次受到伤害，避免我们的自我受到侵犯，
to maintain our sense of self-worth and respect. So those are three theories as to why we experience resentment so profoundly. It's an emotional alarm to something that needs to change in our lives. It is a sign of what we care about and it's a way of protecting us. I want to offer one final perspective here. And you know what? I don't agree with it, but maybe it will resonate with you.
to maintain our sense of self-worth and respect. So those are three theories as to why we experience resentment so profoundly. It's an emotional alarm to something that needs to change in our lives. It is a sign of what we care about and it's a way of protecting us. I want to offer one final perspective here. And you know what? I don't agree with it, but maybe it will resonate with you.|||从而维护我们的自尊心和尊重感。这就是关于为什么我们会如此深刻地体验到怨恨的三种理论。它是生活中需要改变的事物的感情警报。它是我们所在乎的事物的标志，也是保护我们的一种方式。我想在这里提出最后一个视角。你知道吗？我并不同意这个观点，但也许它会引起你的共鸣。
I think it's important to always offer some other explanations just because they don't align with my beliefs. doesn't mean there isn't some truth in them. One of the leading psychologists and researchers on resentment, Dr. Steven Stonzie, he wrote some really fascinating articles around his belief that resentment is actually quite selfish and in his words, narcissistic. So he kind of believes that resentment actually shouldn't be normalized because it closes us off from others and it makes us defensive. He says that resentment is like anger.
I think it's important to always offer some other explanations just because they don't align with my beliefs. doesn't mean there isn't some truth in them. One of the leading psychologists and researchers on resentment, Dr. Steven Stonzie, he wrote some really fascinating articles around his belief that resentment is actually quite selfish and in his words, narcissistic. So he kind of believes that resentment actually shouldn't be normalized because it closes us off from others and it makes us defensive. He says that resentment is like anger.|||我认为始终提供一些其他的解释是很重要的，仅仅因为它们与我的信仰不一致，并不意味着其中没有道理。怨恨领域的主要心理学家和研究人员之一，斯蒂芬·斯通齐博士（Dr. Steven Stonzie），写了一些非常引人入胜的文章，阐述了他对怨恨的看法：他认为怨恨其实相当自私，用他的话说，是自恋的。因此，他某种程度上认为怨恨其实不应该被正常化，因为它让我们与他人隔绝，让我们充满防御心。他说怨恨就像愤怒一样。
It actually cuts us off from higher emotions that would allow us to. heal and repair. So when you experience resentment, it's best to kind of talk yourself out of it, to get over your ego, to forgive and move forward. Listen, I get the sentiment. I totally do, but I think that you can get back to those higher emotions, as he calls them, without suppressing those initial feelings that have come up. I kind of get where he's coming from. I think resentment is somewhat self-centered, but not selfish. It's based on your reality, not on someone else's. That doesn't make it bad. When you don't have the closure from that experience and why it created resentment, when you are kind of told to just move on, when you haven't worked through the why, I think you just
It actually cuts us off from higher emotions that would allow us to. heal and repair. So when you experience resentment, it's best to kind of talk yourself out of it, to get over your ego, to forgive and move forward. Listen, I get the sentiment. I totally do, but I think that you can get back to those higher emotions, as he calls them, without suppressing those initial feelings that have come up. I kind of get where he's coming from. I think resentment is somewhat self-centered, but not selfish. It's based on your reality, not on someone else's. That doesn't make it bad. When you don't have the closure from that experience and why it created resentment, when you are kind of told to just move on, when you haven't worked through the why, I think you just|||它实际上切断了我们与那些能够让我们治愈和修复的更高尚情感的联系。因此，当你体验到怨恨时，最好是说服自己放下，克服你的自我，去原谅并向前看。听着，我理解这种情绪。我完全理解，但我认为，你完全可以在不压抑最初产生的那些情绪的情况下，重新回到他所说的那些更高尚的情感中去。我大致能理解他的出发点。我认为怨恨在某种程度上是以自我为中心的，但并不自私。它基于你自己的现实，而不是别人的现实。这并不意味着它是坏事。当你没有从那段经历中获得了解脱、没有弄清它为什么会产生怨恨，当你被告知要继续前进、却没有理清“为什么”时，我想你只会。
reenter a cycle where you can never get to a more enlightened and positive space, right? You might just end up staying in relationships that actually you have a real reason to feel resentful. You aren't treated with respect. You aren't given what you deserve. So actually, you need to learn and listen to this feeling because it is kind of guiding your life. It is giving you an alarm to return to that former explanation. So that's another perspective. There's a couple of perspectives, actually. You can choose which one you think best suits, maybe the resentment that you experience. But the next question we obviously have is, what do we do about it? We don't want resentment to rule our lives, but we also can't avoid it. We can't just keep feeding the beast. We can't just keep
reenter a cycle where you can never get to a more enlightened and positive space, right? You might just end up staying in relationships that actually you have a real reason to feel resentful. You aren't treated with respect. You aren't given what you deserve. So actually, you need to learn and listen to this feeling because it is kind of guiding your life. It is giving you an alarm to return to that former explanation. So that's another perspective. There's a couple of perspectives, actually. You can choose which one you think best suits, maybe the resentment that you experience. But the next question we obviously have is, what do we do about it? We don't want resentment to rule our lives, but we also can't avoid it. We can't just keep feeding the beast. We can't just keep|||再次陷入一个永远无法达到更开明、更积极境界的循环中，对吧？你可能最终只会留在那些实际上你有充分理由感到怨恨的关系中。你没有得到应有的尊重。你没有得到你应得的对待。所以实际上，你需要学习并倾听这种感觉，因为它在某种程度上引导着你的生活。它给你拉响了警报，让你回到之前的解释中。所以这是另一个视角。事实上，还有好几个视角。你可以选择你认为最适合你的那种视角，或许能契合你所经历的怨恨。但我们显然后面要提出的问题是，我们该对此做些什么呢？我们不希望怨恨主宰我们的生活，但我们也无法避开它。我们不能一直纵容这种情绪。我们不能一直。
suppressing it. So we're going to talk about how to move through it and so much more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look at the science. past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
suppressing it. So we're going to talk about how to move through it and so much more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers and other health and fitness experts and more to look at the science. past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.|||压抑它。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论如何度过这一情绪以及更多内容。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等人进行交流，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信植物油天生具有致炎性。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?|||我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上的 T-W-O-Persent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crap. in the 80s.
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crap. in the 80s.|||好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论 20 世纪 80 年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||澄清一下，84 年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这儿，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的脉络了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以……现在你把这句话说完了。是的。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the I-Hard Rout. Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the I-Hard Rout. Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host,|||真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人，
experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses.|||也就是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，并与许多杰出的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，但我们仍在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌，生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，是因为你们觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你们因为害怕才做一个好人？因为老兄，这是两种不同的动机。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast. Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，由我，凯尔·盖恩斯，与大家一起就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和目标展开真实的对话。在 iHeartRadio App 上免费学习。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她证词中明显的矛盾之处。由此展开了长达数年的法庭之争以证明真相。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过测试。这需要一群网络侦探来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trap》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. At the very beginning of this episode, I presented you with kind of three options for dealing with your resentment. You can harbor, you can ignore, or you can release. I want to tell you about what happens to your body and your emotional state and your relationships. If,
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。在本集的最开始，我为您提供了处理怨恨的三种选择。你可以怀恨在心，你可以忽视，或者你可以释放。我想告诉你，如果，
you choose number one or two, if you believe that resentment is better left unseen. As time goes on, it builds up and this causes a domino effect that turns into anger, bitterness, disappointment, potentially hatred. That is really explosive to our relationships because when we don't express why we are hurt, why we are angry, we don't really give the other person an opportunity to repair, to reflect, to fix things, you know, basically you stone wall yourself and that relationship, there's no getting past it, which is quite sad. Obviously, sometimes like I said, you know, I feel the need to justify this. Sometimes it's valid. Sometimes it's necessary. But I think about a couple of friendships I lost when I was a teenager or in my very early 20s that I think I really could
你选择了第一种或第二种，如果你认为怨恨最好不要被看到，会发生什么。随着时间的推移，它会积聚起来，并产生多米诺骨效应，变成愤怒、痛苦、失望，甚至可能是仇恨。这对我们的关系具有极大的破坏性，因为当我们不表达我们为什么受伤、为什么生气时，我们实际上并没有给对方一个修复、反思、解决问题的机会，你知道的，基本上你把自己和那段关系筑起了一道高墙，无法走出来，这相当令人难过。显然，有时就像我说的，你知道，我觉得有必要为自己辩解。有时这是有道理的。有时这是必要的。但我想起我十几岁或二十岁出头时失去的一段友谊，我想如果我
have saved if I'd swollen my pride and being honest about what I was finding issue with. you know, I never gave those people the chance that I'm sure, you know, I now would, and that I'm sure some of my friends have given me when I've messed up, when I've not met the expectations for our relationship. It's kind of like the moment you feel resentment is the moment that the relationship ends if your only option is to ignore it or to harbor it. It can also have more long-term effects, such as, you know, the development of a very hostile, cynical attitude derived from,
咽下自尊，诚实地表达我所发现的问题，我真的本可以挽救它们。你知道的，我从未给过那些人机会，而我相信，你知道的，我现在会给，而且我相信当我搞砸了，当我没有达到我们关系的期望时，我的一些朋友也曾给过我机会。这有点像你感到怨恨的那一刻，就是关系结束的那一刻，如果你的唯一选择是忽视它或怀恨在心的话。它还可能产生更长期的影响，例如，你知道的，由于，
emotional pain, which can eventually become a barrier against future healthy relationships. This is a hard one because inherent to letting go of our resentment is also an element of forgiveness and letting things settle and be excused for your own sake. Let's be real for a second. There are some people we cannot give that to. The transgression has been too great. The hurt has been too much. But in those moments, it's important to remember that your resentment is there to protect you and to reinforce what you do deserve, but that doesn't mean that it should numb you. It doesn't mean that it should hold you back or that it should teach you that the world is harsh and that people are inherently mean. You know, your resentment can be reserved for that one person and resolved by taking the action
情感痛苦而产生一种非常敌意、愤世嫉俗的态度，这最终可能成为未来健康关系的障碍。这是一个棘手的问题，因为放下怨恨本身也包含着原谅的成分，为了你自己的利益，让事情平息并被原谅。现实一点吧。有些人我们无法给予原谅。这种越界的行为太严重了。受到的伤害太深了。但在那些时刻，重要的是要记住，你的怨恨是为了保护你，并强化你应得的东西，但这并不意味着它应该让你麻木。这并不意味着它应该阻碍你，或者它应该教导你世界是残酷的，人们生来就是刻薄的。你知道的，你的怨恨可以留给那个人，并通过采取
to distance yourself without taking over. Chronic resentment. especially directed towards people who remain in your lives, but with whom we never address it, can also start our emotional growth. It creates a lot of difficulty in self-disclosure, right? Trouble trusting others. If we are constantly ruminating on this instance in which we felt let down, or we felt kind of burned or excluded, or that made you feel like you were double-cross, whatever it is, it's going to make.
疏远的行动来解决，而不会失控。长期的怨恨，尤其是针对那些仍然留在你生活中，但我们从未与他们解决问题的人，也开始阻碍我们的情感成长。它在自我表露方面造成了很大的困难，对吧？难以信任他人。如果我们不断地回味这种让我们感到失望、感到被伤害或被排挤、或者让你觉得被双重背叛的情况，无论是什么，它都会使。
you the kind of person who goes to trust other people, who goes to open up to other people and is reminded about this previous experience and immediately shuts down. That is, I think, the emotional consequence that we have from shaming our resentment or from feeling like the only choice is either I have to forgive this person completely or I have to just move on and suppress what I've gone through. And it also has physical consequences, which I think we don't often speak about in this conversation. If there is one thing we talk about so much on this podcast,
你成为这样的人，当想要信任其他人、向其他人敞开心扉时，会被提醒这段经历并立即关闭心扉。我认为，这是我们因对怨恨感到羞耻，或觉得唯一的选择要么是完全原谅这个人，要么只能继续前进并压抑自己所经历的一切，而带来的情感后果。它还会带来生理后果，我认为我们在这种对话中往往不会谈论这一点。如果说我们在本播客中经常谈论一件事，
it's that emotions have a physical form. I think if you've ever read, The Body Keeps the Score, you would know that. I speak about it so often. I'm so sorry to sound like, you know, a record on repeat. But more often than not, you know, emotions are not just restricted to our minds. they manifest in our body through tension, through stress, through the release of cortisol and other stress hormones, through an increased heart rate or blood pressure. And again, Dr. Stonsi,
那就是情绪具有身体形态。我想如果你读过《身体记得这一切》，你就会知道这一点。我经常谈论它。很抱歉听起来像是一张，你知道的，不断重复的唱片。但更多时候，你知道的，情绪不仅仅局限于我们的头脑。它们通过紧张、压力、皮质醇和其他应激激素的释放、心率或血压的升高在我们的身体中表现出来。再次说明，斯通西博士，
who we spoke about before, he actually did some further research on this back in 2012 and 2013. And he found that in a number of patients that had prolonged chronic resentment, this can lead to the constriction of nerve endings in our muscle. that causes basically low-grade muscle and back pain, but it can also result in the destruction of T cells, meaning that we get sick more often, our immune system is lowered, things like hypertension as well, substance abuse, depression, anxiety. What he basically says is that your resentment is making you sick.
我们之前谈到过他，他在 2012 年和 2013 年对这一点进行了一些更深入的研究。他发现，在许多患有长期慢性怨恨的患者中，这会导致我们肌肉中神经末梢的收缩。这基本上会导致轻度的肌肉和背痛，但也可能导致 T 细胞的破坏，这意味着我们更容易生病，我们的免疫系统下降，还有高血压等问题、药物滥用、抑郁、焦虑。他基本上想说的是，你的怨恨正在让你生病。
But does that mean that we need to go with the path of instant forgiveness? I think that we can move through it. So let's talk about the ways that we can release our resentment. Firstly, there is so much that can be repaired by being open and soft and communicating how you're feeling. If this person is a friend that you've never had an issue with before or they are a really loving partner or a sibling, the best option, and I know it is one that often requires us to swallow our pride, is to talk about why you're feeling that way and to try and gain some perspective. There is this technique currently being studied at UC Berkeley called self-distance
但这是否意味着我们需要走即时原谅的道路？我认为我们可以克服它。所以让我们谈谈我们可以释放怨恨的方法。首先，通过开放、温柔和沟通你的感受，有很多事情是可以修复的。如果这个人是你从未有过问题的朋友，或者他们是一个非常慈爱的伴侣或兄弟姐妹，最好的选择，我知道这通常需要我们咽下自尊，就是谈论你为什么会有这种感觉，并试图获得一些视角。目前加州大学伯克利分校正在研究一种名为自我距离的技术，
that I think helps us put ourselves into the lives and into the shoes of others. What you do with self-distance is replay the event but from a third-person perspective instead of from your perspective. So in their research, the authors asked participants to recall a conflict from a close personal relationship that was still unresolved and that was upsetting. You know, some people recalled the situation from a first person perspective where they were right there in the moment with the other person. And other people were asked to use self-distancing. And they were asked to recall the situation from a third person point of view as if they were kind of like a fly on the wall.
我认为这有助于我们把自己置于他人的生活和处境中。你用自我距离所做的是重播这个事件，但从第三人称的视角，而不是从你的视角。因此，在他们的研究中，作者要求参与者回忆亲密个人关系中尚未解决且令人沮丧的冲突。你知道的，有些人从第一人称视角回忆当时的情况，他们当时就在现场和另一个人在一起。而另一些人则被要求使用自我距离。他们被要求从第三人称的角度回忆当时的情况，就好像他们是墙上的苍蝇一样。
Like, okay, what did you do? And then what did they do? Which was kind of counter to the opposite, you know, perspective, the first person perspective, which was very much, okay, what did you feel? What did you observe? What was your interpretation? And what they found is that participants who used self-distance experienced much less intense emotional and physical reactions. Physically, they had a lower rise in blood pressure. And even if their blood pressure did rise, it went back to the baseline quicker.
就像，好的，你做了什么？然后他们做了什么？这与相反的视角，即第一人称视角有点背道而驰，第一人称视角非常强调，好的，你感受到了什么？你观察到了什么？你的解读是什么？他们发现，使用自我距离的参与者体验到强度小得多的情绪和生理反应。在生理上，他们的血压上升幅度较小。即使他们的血压确实上升了，它也能更快地恢复到基线水平。
And emotionally, they felt less triggered and less kind of heightened and stressed overall. And here's the kicker. The people who experienced and who were asked to institute self-distancing, they actually ended up experiencing more closure. They were more motivated to find a resolution with the other person, not just by immediately offering forgiveness, but by seeing how the other person acted, and not just being able to have empathy for that,
在情绪上，他们感到不那么容易被触发，总的来说，不那么高度紧张和焦虑。最棒的是。体验并被要求建立自我距离的人，实际上最终体验到了更多的心结解开。他们更有动力与对方达成解决方案，不仅是通过立即提供原谅，而是通过看到对方的行为，不仅能够对之产生同理心，
but for kind of seeing things more realistically, more realistically, maybe that's a better word, more realistically. it is really hard to lose a relationship. Even if the pain happens over time, I think there is less pain if you have determined that the relationship is worth saving with just biting the bullet. And it shows a sense of self-respect. People shouldn't need a reminder of how to treat you.
而且能以更现实的方式看待事物，更现实地，也许这是一个更好的词，更现实地。失去一段感情真的很难。即使痛苦随着时间推移而发生，我认为如果你已经决定这段关系值得通过咬紧牙关来挽救，痛苦就会少一些。这也表现出一种自尊。人们不应该需要别人提醒如何对待你。
Let's just say that. But maybe they need a reminder of how you perceive their actions as meaning one thing when maybe they do mean something else. Or maybe there is a gap between what you're expecting, from someone and what they're able to give you. This is something, you know, I've quite frankly discovered with friends. Instead of resenting them for, you know, not showing up for me the way that I want, not making plans every weekend, maybe flaking on plans, I just reel back my expectations
我们只能这么说。但也许他们需要提醒，你如何将他们的行为理解为一回事，而也许它们意味着其他事情。或者，你对某人的期望与他们能够给予你的能力之间存在差距。这是我坦率地在朋友身上发现的一些东西。我没有因为他们没有以我想要的方式支持我、没有每个周末都做计划、或者可能放鸽子而对他们心怀怨恨，而是降低了对他们的期望，
for them and I lowered the stakes of our friendship. The person is still part of my life. It's not like I think they're terrible and neglectful and deserve no second chances. It's actually that I realize I can't control. their behavior, but I'm just going to be more realistic and therefore less disappointed. The resentment also fades, which I think honestly is the main goal here. I just think that a lot of the time, if you can't overcome the resentment, if you feel like they keep not meeting your expectations, it's time to lower your expectations and it's
并降低了我们友谊的风险。这个人仍然是我生活的一部分。并不是我认为他们很糟糕、很忽视人且不值得任何第二次机会。实际上是我意识到我无法控制他们的行为，但我会变得更现实，因此减少失望。怨恨也会消退，我认为老实说这是这里的最终目标。我只是觉得很多时候，如果你无法克服怨恨，如果你觉得他们一直没有达到你的期望，是时候降低你的期望了，
time to let that person, give that person less opportunities to fail you by kind of of reducing their importance in your life. You know, obviously if this is your boyfriend or your partner, that's not an option. Because reducing your expectations sometimes means reducing your expectation for what you deserve. So there is obviously a judgment call here. There is a judgment call. If it is someone who is particularly close to you, maybe that is the thing to remind yourself. I shouldn't have to tell someone what I deserve.
并通过减少他们在你生活中的重要性，给那个人更少让你失望的机会。当然，如果这是你的男朋友或伴侣，这不是一个选择。因为降低期望有时意味着降低你对你应得之物的期望。所以这显然需要做出判断。这需要做出判断。如果是一个与你特别亲密的人，也许这就是你需要提醒自己的事情。我不应该去告诉别人我配得上什么。
I shouldn't have to tell someone how to treat me. Is that a sign that your resentment is an emotional warning? Honestly, I don't think that I can answer that for all of you individually. But I do want to give you some final tips about how to heal through your resentment from the psychologist, Dr. Susan Albers. So firstly, locate your resentment in the mind. Why do you feel resentment and track back to a specific behavior? and what was it about the behavior that perhaps showed you that something that you cared about
我不应该告诉别人如何对待我。这是否表明你的怨恨是一个情感警告？老实说，我想我无法为你们所有人单独回答这个问题。但我确实想就如何通过心理学家苏珊·阿尔伯斯博士的指导来治愈你的怨恨给你一些最后的小建议。首先，在脑海中定位你的怨恨。你为什么会感到怨恨，并追溯到一个特定的行为？以及该行为的什么地方可能向你表明，你所关心的事情
was not being respected in that moment? Then once you've located it in the mind, locate it in the body. Where are you feeling this? Where is the tension? Whereas the exhaustion felt by your resentment? And right about it. Is the reason this feels particularly brutal because there's some history there? Is there a former offense or experience?
在那一刻没有受到尊重？然后一旦你在脑海中定位了它，就在身体中定位它。你在哪里感受到这个？紧张在哪里？你的怨恨带来的疲惫感在哪里？并写下来。这种感觉特别残酷的原因是因为其中有一些历史吗？是否有过去的冒犯或经历
that made you feel neglected or hurt in the past. And is that why this feels particularly rough? If that is so, you know, the saying about, fool me twice, fool me three times. Maybe they don't deserve another chance. Reenforce what it is to you that you do and don't deserve. You deserve respect. You deserve kindness.
让你在过去感到被忽视或受伤？这就是为什么这感觉特别艰难吗？如果是这样，你知道那句俗语，骗我两次，骗我三次。也许他们不配得到另一次机会。强化你应得的和不应得的是什么。你值得尊重。你值得善良。
You deserve reciprocity. You deserve generosity and love. And if that person, if this resentment is coming from a place where you don't feel like they gave you that and they don't respect your needs, that's definitely going to be a bigger conversation. Does it involve stepping back from the relationship, explaining to the person why? Does it involve being like, okay, this is my interpretation? Can you explain?
你值得对等。你值得慷慨和爱。如果那个人，如果这种怨恨来自于你觉得他们没有给你这些并且他们不尊重你的需求的地方，那这绝对会是一场更大的对话。这是否涉及从关系中退一步，向对方解释原因？这是否涉及说，好的，这是我的解读？你能解释一下吗？
Can you talk to me? Can you talk me through this? Or does it involve something else? I think above all else, we don't want to feel burdened by an emotional reaction that we can't control, right? Like that's the main thing we're saying here. Resentment is not helpful, beneficial when you let it sit in your body and sit in your mind. And you ruminate on it and you never reach a resolution. So that's where I think writing about it really helps.
你能跟我谈谈吗？你能带我度过这个难关吗？还是说这涉及其他事情？我认为最重要的是，我们不想背负无法控制的情绪反应的负担，对吧？就像这是我们在这里所说的主旨。当让怨恨停留在你的身体和脑海中时，怨恨是没有帮助的、没有益处的。当你对它反复咀嚼却从未达成解决方案时。所以这就是我认为写下来真正有帮助的地方。
It brings clarity, but it also brings you some more peace. You know, it makes the feeling tangible and therefore offers you a release. So next, really accept the feeling. And think about the above options. Will your life improve if you cling on to this feeling? or would you be better moving on and finding a way to, you know, either release, either harbor or ignore, hopefully you choose release. And finally, that release comes from deciding what you're going to do. Are you going to self-distance? Are you going to discuss? Are you going to lower expectations?
它带来了清晰，但也带给你更多的平静。你知道的，它让这种感觉变得切实可见，从而为你提供了一个释放的途径。所以接下来，真正接受这种感觉。并考虑上述选项。如果你坚持这种感觉，你的生活会改善吗？还是你最好继续前进并找到方法，你知道的，要么释放，要么怀恨，要么忽视，希望你选择释放。最后，这种释放来自于决定你要做什么。你要自我疏远吗？你要去讨论吗？你要降低期望吗？
I think that's a big one when it comes to things like work, right? Like, yeah, you know what? I feel like my expectations towards this workplace so that they think of me as family. Obviously, they've shown me that they don't, or my expectation is that I would get promoted or that they cared about my work. Obviously, they don't. Lower your expectations, lower your effort. Or are you going to channel this into something positive? Are you going to channel this into moving forward and finding, you know, if it's a partner who is treated on you, finding someone new.
我认为在工作之类的事情上，这是一个很大的因素，对吧？就像，好吧，你知道吗？我觉得我对这个工作场所的期望是他们把我当成家人。显然，他们向我表明他们没有，或者我的期望是我会得到晋升或者他们关心我的工作。显然，他们没有。降低你的期望，减少你的努力。或者你要把这个转化为积极的事情吗？你要把它转化为向前迈进并找到，你知道的，如果是一个背叛你的伴侣，找到一个新的人。
Basically, that's up to you, right? But the one thing I want you to take away from this, resentment is an alarm. Resentment is teaching you something. and you need to choose a way to move forward with it that doesn't necessarily involve forgiveness, but does involve peace for yourself, whatever the circumstance. And maybe a bonus takeaway, I do think that talking about our feelings when it does seem necessary is very brave and courageous and is the thing that you should do. I don't want you to be sacrificing relationships from a place of resentment
基本上，这取决于你，对吧？但我希望你从中带走的一件事是，怨恨是一个警报。怨恨正在教给你一些东西。你需要选择一种与之一起前进的方式，这不一定涉及原谅，但无论在什么情况下，都要为自己争取到内心的平静。也许还有一个额外的心得，我确实认为在似乎必要的时候谈论我们的感受是非常勇敢的，并且是你应该做的事情。我不想让你在甚至还不完全了解需要知道的一切、每个人的解读以及他们给情况带来的东西之前，
before you even understand everything that needs to be known and everybody's interpretation and what they're bringing to the situation if that is right for you. So I really hope that this episode helped. I hope that you just understand resentment a little bit more and you understand that it's not a bad or an ugly or a negative emotion as some would like to call it. It is not entitlement. It comes from a place of self-respect and knowing what you deserve, which is a good thing. As always, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Make sure that you are following along for future episodes.
就从怨恨的角度放弃那些关系，如果这适合你的话。所以我真的希望这一集有帮助。我希望你能多理解一点怨恨，并且明白它并不是某些人所说的那种糟糕、丑陋或消极的情绪。这不是一种特权。它来自于自尊和知道你应得之物的地方，这是一件好事。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星评价。确保关注未来的剧集。
And if you have a suggestion for a topic that you would like to cover around the psychology of our 20s, I would love to hear from you at That Psychology Podcast. Until next time, remember to stay safe, be kind to yourself, be gentle to yourself, especially when it comes to resentment. We've talked about some heavy stuff today. And until next time, we will talk very very. Very, very soon. 2%.
如果你对我们20多岁心理学主题有任何建议，我很乐意在 That Psychology Podcast 听到你的声音。直到下次，记得保持安全，善待自己，对温柔自己，尤其是在面对怨恨时。我们今天谈论了一些沉重的事情。直到下次，我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、健康和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 IHeart Radio App 上的 TWO%。Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you. I got you. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。我挺你。我挺你。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是 Sam J。我是 Alex English。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。这是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。这是一个 IHeart 播客，保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。